bonjour monsieur
et bien une douche s'il vous plaît
[Musique]
construit à une époque où l'accès de
tout ça l'hygiène constitue une
préoccupation majeure ils affichent
fièrement leur vocation bains
leur service a beaucoup de Parisiens
[Musique]
d'accord
voilà merci au revoir
d'abord chaque établissement occupe au
moins 6 personnes la caissière qui
connaît tout le monde
elle est bien ça va les hommes de
l'accueil qui veillent sur les cabines
et sur le temps de leur utilisation 20
minutes pas plus
et enfin les chauffagistes qui
entretiennent une véritable petite usine
pour fournir des fleuves d'eau chaude au
millier de clients qui se douche ici
chaque semaine
en effet plus d'un logement sur 10 à
Paris ne possède pas de sanitaires
[Musique]
lui c'est Paul doudou 87 printemps aux
cerises comme il dit
et bien une douche s'il vous plaît
il a vu naître ce bain douche il y a 60
ans et depuis la constamment fréquenté
[Applaudissements]
mécanicien d'avion et même vélo taxi
avec l'adresse et la malice du parigot
pur jus qu'il est il vient d'eau douce
comme d'autres vont à la messe en latin
[Musique]
on est depuis 75 ans à l'époque on
n'avait pas de douche on était
extrêmement petitement logé aujourd'hui
dans un ancien placard on voulait un
salle des douches bah à l'époque on
faisait pas ça on est au douche
alors les douches elles étaient devant
toute la semaine jusqu'à 7h du soir
facile mais alors c'était plein archi
plein
et alors il y avait une ambiance à
l'époque il y avait pas la télé ou la
radio comme maintenant
les gants prenant les douches ils
poussaient la romance
sérieux puis Oriane avait l'autre qui
répondait
[Musique]
que dans la vapeur bleutée
fait peur c'est sûr ils paieront pour
leurs erreurs femmes punaise qu'un objet
dans ce miroir tes désirs sont ceux
d'argent et du pouvoir en un certain
pouvoir
de grenadine la vie
est un muffins serré par leurs parents
en boucle noir adieu donc musette et
accordéon Yves John chômeur voudrait
bien traduire sarage en mot mais dans
son désarroi il a oublié l'air et
l'accent de Paris je vais te montrer un
petit rap pour les amis
voilà quoi
dans la télévision un dualiste imbécile
égoïste a raison publicité pour les
privilégiés systèmes inhumains d'excus
et prisonniers c'est pas mal
les Bains douches sont des satellites
les bistrots du voisinage c'est le
rendez-vous de l'après douche quand bien
propre et récuré on vient prendre
quelque chose de chaud celui-ci
s'appelle évidemment le relais des
douches les gens viennent ici avec leur
accordéon ou leur guitare l'habitude est
ancienne seule la musique a un peu
changé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'anime Guilbault et ses deux fils se
rendent ensemble au bain douche de
l'Ermitage comme elle-même enfant elle y
accompagné sa mère
bonjour bonjour
3 places trois shampoings
[Musique]
à tout à l'heure
c'est un rite qui se perpétue tout comme
d'habitude de parler à des inconnus pour
le plaisir d'échanger des mots derrière
comme ça
on est gâté par les astres
Janine Guibout le sait bien elle qui
revient toujours
à la maison
de deux même si j'avais la douche bon
c'est un contact à voir avec les gens
enfin c'est un plaisir de venir dans les
douches
Christophe
ah bah ça y est
quoi comme ça alors
[Musique]
des petits copains qui viennent se laver
aussi qui n'ont pas qui n'ont pas douche
ou qui se retrouvent ici pour pouvoir
discuter
et à scène il est pas venu aussi
[Musique]
les derniers clients s'en vont ils ne
pourront revenir que vendredi prochain
les douches s'endorment donc pour toute
une semaine
[Musique]